joining us now is the actor Josh Duhamel
stars in the transformer series the
pride of Minot North Dakota and got up
early to come out here and hit a couple
of balls on the range with us so we
appreciate that Josh
I don't you up till 11 and yet so much I
like you guys and I love the Hat he's
got a hat that says four on it very
appropriate do you say four during your
round yesterday
well you it's important out here because
there's people that are watching they
think you're good by the way like the
the gallery thinks the players the
celebrities are good and they get really
close yes yeah I don't know I don't know
if they think I'm very good and that's
no joke hence the Hat do you wear the
Air Jordans on the court you got your
Air Jordans no I again I thought we were
doing a radio guys you always do this
Josh don't you understand there's
cameras you go on that's right it's it's
it's it's the DP show you know yeah I
got to expect you guys into something
big so I figured every other year that I
come to this there's they have a little
media yeah go do some radio and then I
Drive past here this morning and I see
the lights I was like oh god here we go
again do you need hair and makeup no I'm
good you're good okay how do you get
into the tournament like how does this
celebrity go about asking to get in here
so several years ago I think this is my
eighth time playing it now I I got asked
to play with
I think Dockers asked me to come and
play or something and came loved it
it had a great time they asked me back
the next year and I just figured as long
as I just keep kissing enough but yeah I
get I get asked back as Fergie been here
to Pebble Beach she comes usually comes
with me I'll shoe to make this trip not
this year she's working yeah she was at
the Super Bowl I stayed home with axel
yeah and then I came here and she's
what are you working on now we just
finished transformers I think I'm gonna
start a 10-episode wash it's not done
yet so just something yes and then and
then I'm moving right after that then
hopefully God willing I'm gonna be
directing my first thing this summer
living writing spent two years I talked
about this with you at dinner
yeah I'm gonna be coming to you you're
gonna need my help
yeah I'm gonna need your help I'm
probably gonna need all these guys no
only all the help I can get
you're not very good at keeping secrets
are you yeah I'm pretty good because
when whenever I have dinner with you you
always tell me something and then you
threatened to kill me if I tell anybody
anything
well there's I don't tell you any
details well yeah when you were getting
ready to have a baby oh and you yelled
at me like that so excited or you were
trying we're 20 and you said hey we're
trying yeah and then yet you said if you
tell anybody I'll kill you and I go whoa
but that's not you like it didn't sound
like it was good news my son showed us I
just really trust me you know that's
when my son showed up and he goes I said
on Josh knew my niece inaccurate he goes
have you been in anything I've seen my
son was such a smartass to you New York
doing advertising okay he's probably
he's probably be directing your next
movie no no no I don't think he wants to
get into that goofy business now with a
sports movie no you're not doing well I
did one I did one called spaceman you
did build me but I thought you were
working on
sowhat's am I allowed to say what the
movie is that you talked about okay so
the thing that I've been working on yeah
so it's based on this thing that we've
been doing for the last 20 years me and
my buddies called the buddy games and
the story is about the last three years
these guys haven't done the games
because there was a bad accident that
happened three years ago
and the guys have kind of drifted one of
the guys lost one of his testicles and
he found out that he lost both of them
and it's been it's sort of like think
think the Big Chill is the darkness and
it's like the Big Chill when they all
come back together yeah the you know
funeral for their old friends while they
all sort of come back together to
reflect on one of their friends balls
[Laughter]
and then having an executive said all
right I'm gonna greenlight that one
totally the story he's just pretending
it's not the story how we react no no no
that's sort of the story it's sort of
the story ultimately ultimately what
happens is they come back they get him
back to get him they get him to come
back because he's been in this dark hole
for three years so check my movie it's a
total bro movie yeah what's the name of
it it's called the buddy games yeah yeah
you got to get a Wahlberg in there don't
you like I'll work on him this weekend
well you might not get marked though one
of them yeah there's a whole lot of them
all right so we'll take a break we'll
continue with the Josh Duhamel my wife
my wife is here and she wanted to know
what time you were gonna be on she was
gonna stop over did she see yeah but she
didn't care about the you know the show
so she's probably still sleeping right
she asked what time you were gonna be on
she didn't ask about anything else today
okay nothing I don't know if she's gonna
come over here so we may do the hot guy
draft fallout remember when you didn't
get drafted in the hot guy draft sorry
we're gonna do a redraft Paul I was that
was wrong
Paul a you were mean-spirited thinking I
got drafted yeah josh is on hold
that's got to be the most upset you've
been in five years yeah all right we'll
come back on her play of the day yeah
Josh Duhamel will be back with us after
this
Paulie B's mean-spirited a couple of
weeks ago we had a hot guy draft it's
the the annual
guy draft on the Dan Patrick show and
was it for four rounds where we all went
through and you know it's like our
fantasy draft yeah I think Ted Koppel
went before this Josh I mean no offense
if but you've read it man
but you call him and you say hey we're
doing a mine guy right you gotta call
the show you got a call show it would be
like a number one first-round draft pick
falling all the way to the end of the
draft yeah I was like it was like Johnny
Manziel you're Aaron Rodgers okay you
don't want to take the man's Hill no
yeah you're you were Aaron Rodgers there
but if we did a redraft for the hot guy
drown just on the property today josh is
the number two overall seed unfortunate
Kelly Slater you know all right you can
admit that but I mean we had Gosling and
yeah yeah yeah I mean you understand
you're starting to get into a dangerous
age bracket but you enjoyed it yet a
great run I did okay the scene you have
what's the movie with Topher Grace yes
and you take your shirt oh yeah that was
Topher's idea by the way
really really okay you know how was the
fallout from that in your your personal
life that movie that was pre Fergie
right that was well before Fergie that
was that was 19 or that was 2002 or
three or four something like that yeah
you know it is you gotta you gotta you
gotta take what you can get when you're
first starting out in the business yeah
you know that was your first movie
though that was my first movie oh wow
yeah first paid acting job was what my
first paid acting job was all my
children were you a New York it was it
was not all my children for three years
I'll see your regular mm-hmm anything
dramatic like you know when it comes to
soap opera acting as opposed to regular
acting or is it the same well no I think
that you have to everything is a little
that heightens when it comes to soaps
and that was that was the beauty of it
for me it was the greatest three years
because I was so green when I first
started there those three years on that
show were great for me because you know
you learned how to you know find your
light learn your lines what how
production works did you interview Mike
was there the emotional moment though do
you ever have one of those where you oh
lot of crying did you cry oh yeah and it
got very dramatic I remember like my big
exit from the show was my mother hated
my new wife and wanted to kill her and
we're on this bridge over this river
they built this big set and it was a
shootout and she tried to shoot my mom I
jumped in front we both fell over the
bridge and Leo goes floating down the
river with his hand just wait that's how
you said so Leo lives you know if they
ever brought the show back I could go I
could go back so you didn't officially
die that's all that's all I left the
show with my hand like sort of a couple
fingers sticking out so similar to De
Niro in Raging Bull you're almost
exactly why it's TV is now the place to
go isn't it we're seeing all these shows
you know that yeah Amazon Hulu Netflix I
mean you name it that's hard to keep up
with all the great stuff I saw there's
really a lot of great TV right now but
what happened where movies were not
movies to you know it's just it's
changed because there's so many
different platforms for people to watch
it now you know they can you know people
gonna watch it on their computers they
can watch it on their phones they can
watch it everywhere and it's harder to
drive people into the theaters therefore
the movies are getting much bigger
they're more tent polish like event type
movies oftentimes remakes of something
or comedies for me those those are the
two things that I go see movies for
usually so you know the smaller movies
it's harder to get people to go see him
because they can watch them in the
comfort of their own private theater
room and also binge watching twos yeah
it's changed television yeah and and
even we're not even watching television
you're watching on your
your tablet yeah that's that's how a lot
of people watch stuff just your sons
three if you said what if he wanted to
get into this business if you said he
could get into music or acting since
since your wife's a singer uh you know I
don't want to push him in any direction
to be honest if he wants to do it I
guess he can do it but I'd rather him
just be a kid and try to keep him as
sort of normal is insulated from it for
as long as I can but how crazy is like
could you imagine Hollywood it can be a
it's a pretty I mean look at poor fritzy
over there what about him
he just looks I mean look at look at you
he looked like he was twenty-two years
old last time I saw him takes its toll
then and then they started working for
Dan stressing effect again I catch
everybody pressures of this business
chews you up and spit you out
twenty-six
yes Paulie Todd look like Josh fifteen
years ago did you ever see a young
pretty he looked like Mark Ruffalo on
steroids I had you never seen anything
like it dude Absolut hunk what a stud
yeah I mean he would in the draft fritzy
would have gotten drafted he would've
definitely twenty it seems like somebody
completely look at that he's the one on
the left
what happened so depressed believe me
dude you look better than Josh did when
he took his shirt off win a date with
tad Hamilton I like that
pretty and Josh Josh is like you know
it's fleeting man it goes for it sees
like amen brother
[Music]
you two have been there we've never been
there power no congratulations you
switch seats you can't tell them apart
it's depressing to look at that because
that looks like a total would you rather
bring break like 1982 or suppose I was
nineteen years old years about probably
by twenty eight years ago okay but you
had a who's the dude next to you his
boyfriend's this kid Corbin you know I
don't want to get personal they were
oiling each other princey did have a
nerf football moment when he said you
said your pants were down to your knees
in your kind of language though he's
Josh Duhamel one of our favorites they
grabbed me Dan great to see you buddy
we'll look for the highlights there
later today playing here at Pebble Beach
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience